Malheureusement, les femmes ont moins d'opportunités
et nous sommes moins prises en compte.
Qui allait considérer mes efforts ?
Mais finalement... il fallait le faire
et apprendre à se défendre, à ne pas oublier sa propre voix.
On entend sans cesse les mêmes choses se répéter,
et j'étais chanceuse d'avoir eu accès à l'éducation.
Si vous pouvez visionner quelque chose, vous pouvez le devenir.
Si vous le voyez, vous pouvez le devenir.
Vous regardez Pat, d'autres guides,
ces orateurs, et regardez-vous aussi,
parce que tout le monde --
tout le monde --
peut faire une chose extraordinaire.
Chaque personne.
PM : Votre histoire, Billie, a inspiré des femmes du monde entier.
Et avec le Leadership Billie Jean King,
vous relevez une cause encore plus grande.
Parce que quand on parle des femmes qui prennent le pouvoir, on parle surtout
de trouver un moyen d'accéder à des postes hauts placés.
Mais vous visez encore plus haut.
On parle d'un leadership global.
Et cette génération a grandi avec une pensée globale --
BJK : C'est formidable ! Regardez la technologie !
Elle nous connecte tous ensemble. C'est une histoire de connexion.
C'est incroyable ce qu'elle permet de rendre possible.
Mais le Leadership Billie Jean King
s'attaque surtout à la main d'oeuvre et essaye de la changer,
pour que les gens puissent aller travailler en étant eux-mêmes.
Beaucoup d'entre nous avons deux boulots :
un pour s'intégrer -- je vais vous donner un exemple.
Une femme afro-américaine se lève une heure plus tôt pour le travail
pour lisser ses cheveux,
et va aux toilettes bien quatre, cinq, six fois par jour
pour relisser ses cheveux et être sûre de s'intégrer.
Elle a deux boulots.
Elle a cet autre travail, quel qu'il soit,
mais elle essaye aussi de s'intégrer.
Ou cet homme qui avait eu un diplôme
à l'université du Michigan,
mais il n'évoquait jamais la pauvreté de sa jeunesse,
il n'en parlait pas.
Il faisait en sorte qu'on le voie comme éduqué.
Il y a aussi cet homme à la NFL --
la ligue de football américain, pour ceux qui l'ignorent,
est un lieu énorme, très macho,
et il parlait de foot tout le temps,
parce qu'il était gay et ne voulait pas que ça se sache.
Et ainsi de suite.
Mon rêve, c'est que chacun puisse être lui-même 7j/7 et 24h/24,
ça serait vraiment l'idéal.
Et on se surprend -- enfin, à ce jour je me surprends
même à propos d'être gay, je me surprends à
(s'étouffe)
être un peu mal à l'aise, à avoir une boule dans le ventre,
à n'être pas totalement bien dans ma peau.
Je crois qu'il faut se demander
si on veut que les gens soient eux-mêmes quoi que ça implique.
PM: La première étude que le Leadership a faite, a montré que
comme pour ces exemples que vous avez pris,
beaucoup de nous ont des difficultés à être authentiques.
Mais vous vous êtes tournée vers la génération du millénaire
qui a bénéficié de toutes ces chances égales --
peut-être pas égales mais qui existent partout --
BJK : J'ai beaucoup de chance.
L'alliance avec Teneo, une entreprise stratégique formidable,
est la raison qui me permet de faire tout ça.
Deux fois dans ma vie,
j'ai été soutenue par des hommes de pouvoir :
il y a longtemps, par Philip Morris et ses Virginia Slims,
et aujourd'hui, pour la deuxième fois de ma vie.
Il y a eu Deloitte.
Je voulais avoir des données -- des faits.
Alors Deloitte a lancé une étude,
et plus de 4000 personnes y ont répondu,
et nous poursuivons au travail.
Et que pense cette génération du millénaire ?
Ils pensent beaucoup, mais ce qui est fantastique avec eux, c'est que
notre génération voulait être représentée
et si on entre dans une pièce, tout le monde est représenté,
mais ça ne leur suffit plus, et c'est tellement bien !
Cette génération est fantastique : ils veulent de la connexion, de l'engagement.
Ils veulent savoir ce que vous ressentez, ce que vous pensez
et trouver une solution.
Ils trouvent des solutions
et ils ont l'information au bout des doigts,
comparé à ce que j'avais plus jeune.
PM : Qu'a montré cette étude sur cette génération ?
Vont-ils faire changer les choses ?
Vont-ils créer un monde où tout le monde pourra travailler ?
BJK : en 2025, 75% des travailleurs dans le monde
seront de cette génération.
Je crois qu'ils vont aider à résoudre des problèmes.
Je pense qu'ils ont les moyens de le faire.
Je sais qu'ils s'en préoccupent.
Ils ont de grandes idées et peuvent faire de grandes choses.
Je veux rester dans le présent avec les jeunes,
je ne veux pas rester en arrière.
(Rires)
PM : Aucune chance !
Mais les résultats de l'étude sur cette génération
ne correspond pas à l'expérience que les gens en ont ?
BJK : Non, enfin, parlons-en. J'ai fait mon propre petit sondage.
J'ai interrogé la génération du Baby-Boom, qui sont leurs patrons, et demandé :
« Que pensez-vous de cette génération ? »
J'ai le sourire et je suis positive,
et ils font cette tête --
(Rires)
« Vous parlez de la génération 'Moi' ? »
« Vous croyez vraiment ? »
Parce qu'ils ont l'air de se soucier de l'environnement
et tout ça.
Et ils répondent « Oh, Billie, ils s'éparpillent. »
(Rires)
Ils ont vraiment prouvé
que le temps de concentration moyen est de 37 secondes à 18 ans.
(Rires)
Ils ne se concentrent pas.
Et ils s'en moquent.
J'ai entendu une histoire l'autre soir :
une femme dirige une galerie avec des employés.
Elle reçoit un SMS d'une employée,
une stagiaire, elle vient de commencer, qui dit :
« Au fait, je vais être en retard parce que je suis chez le coiffeur. »
(Rires)
Elle arrive et la patronne lui dit :
« C'est quoi ce travail ? »
Et elle dit : « Oh je suis en retard, désolée, ça va ? »
Alors elle répond : « Tu sais quoi ? Je veux que tu partes, tu as terminé. »
L'autre dit : « OK. »
(Rires)
Aucun problème !
PM : Billie, cette histoire --
Je sais, mais c'est ce qui effraie les Boomers --
Je vous le dis juste -- c'est bien que tout le monde sache.
(Rires)
C'est bon à savoir,
parce que nous sommes nous-mêmes et ce que nous ressentons,
alors il faut l'accepter dans les deux sens.
Mais j'ai vraiment la foi parce que --
si vous avez fait du sport comme moi --
chaque génération s'améliore.
C'est un fait.
Avec la Fondation Féminine du Sport, nous essayons de protéger la loi
et de conserver le Titre IX,
parce qu'il est toujours dans une position précaire,
et nous sommes très préoccupées,
nous faisons beaucoup de recherches.
C'est très important pour nous.
Je veux écouter les gens.
Mais il faut vraiment protéger ce que le Titre IX défend à travers le monde.
Vous avez déjà entendu le Président Carter parler de protéger le Titre IX.
Et saviez-vous que chaque procès
déposé par des femmes, au moins en sport,
contre n'importe quelle institution,
a été gagné ?
Le Titre IX est là pour nous protéger.
C'est formidable.
Mais nous devons encore faire changer les esprits et les cœurs --
Le chemin est long pour qu'ils rejoignent la législation.
PM : Qu'est-ce qui vous fait vous lever le matin ?
Qu'est-ce qui alimente votre travail,
votre bataille pour l'égalité, qui l'étend,
dans de nouveaux domaines et de nouveaux moyens ?
BJK : Eh bien je rendais mes parents fous parce que j'étais curieuse de tout.
Je suis extrêmement motivée.
Mon petit frère faisait du baseball avec la Ligue Majeure de Baseball.
Mes pauvres parents se fichaient que nous soyons bons.
(Rires)
On les a rendus fous parce qu'on repoussait nos limites,
on les repoussait pour être les meilleurs.
Et c'est grâce à ce que j'entends aux conférences de TED.
Je crois qu'écouter toutes ces femmes,
écouter toutes ces personnes,
écouter le Président Carter -- 90 ans, au passage,
et il citait toutes ces statistiques que je n'avais jamais --
j'aurais dû lui dire :
« Excusez-moi, je dois faire une liste de ces chiffres. »
Il les débitait -- Mais c'est formidable, pardon.
PM : C'est un homme formidable.
(Applaudissements)
BJK : Et il y a aussi la Présidente Mary Robinson
qui est une ancienne présidente --
Merci, les Irlandais ! 62% ! LGBTQ ! Ouais !
(Applaudissements)
Le Congrès votera en juin le mariage des personnes de même sexe,
et c'est bien pour certaines personnes qui ont du mal à se faire entendre.
Mais n'oubliez pas que chacun d'entre nous est un individu,
un être humain avec un cœur qui bat,
qui veut vivre sa propre vie.
OK ? Vous n'avez pas à être d'accord avec quelqu'un
mais tout le monde a cette possibilité.
Je crois que nous devons tous
continuer de faire avancer les choses.
Et ces gens m'ont tellement inspirée.
Chacun de nous compte.
Et chacun de vous peut les influencer.
Vous qui nous écoutez, autour du monde, et les gens qui sont ici --
chaque personne peut influencer les choses.
N'oubliez jamais ça. D'accord ?
Ne vous laissez jamais de côté.
PM : Billie, tu nous as beaucoup inspirés.
BJK : Merci, Pat !
(Applaudissements)
Merci, TED !
Merci beaucoup !